today we're actually going to talk some
pop culture
that's like a buoy on top of a rat yeah
you know i happen to like me just a
little bit of pop culture and there's a
lot going on drew
um well there's uh a latest story
uh conscious uncoupling thank you
gwyneth paltrow for that
ever so useful euphemism people reports
that ben
affleck and anna de armas have split
after
almost a year of dating and uh i guess
ben put this cardboard cut out of her
and
kicked it to the curb actual life-size
cardboard cutout
being put in the trash that is very
unique to have a cardboard cut out
of your partner what do you think wrong
well why do you have to put the whole
cardboard cutout out front and
you know it's like it's always confusing
the green bins for recycling which one's
for the x
i don't know that's that was a little
hardcore but it does beg the question
what do you do when you break up with
somebody and you have a bunch of their
stuff maybe not a cardboard cutout but
their stuff do you give it back to them
do you treat it nicely what do you do i
used to like save all these mementos in
boxes and then all the relationship
would end up like boxes in my closet and
i don't know where
any of it is now i've lost it all are
you friends with x are you friendly
yeah totally yeah me too a lot of people
are not capable of that
you know i had to learn if your like
current person isn't okay with it like
you don't need to stand on ceremony
probably be like this is who i am
i'm friends with my exes you're gonna
have to gauge it from person to person
but
i like things to be amicable there was
something good there
i think once you love somebody you have
to if you're in love with somebody once
you should love them forever
in any way that you can keep that
cardboard cut out
well let's not go that far dear we do
have to move on all right you're
next uh and someone who knows a lot
about moving on and breakups and makeups
is everyone's favorite
carrie bradshaw andrew i can't wait for
sarah jessica parker's sex in the city
return
it's coming soon everybody remember we
announced just a couple weeks ago well
in the meantime the daily mail says sjp
has been super busy at her other job
slinging slingbacks
uh she has two sap collection stores
right here in the city and she actually
goes to work you guys she goes
to the shoe store and personally helps
customers there she is right there
you go and they're like i need a size do
you have a size 10 in these sj and she
goes and gets them for you
um and i i wonder if she's kicking it
like assistant manager style and she has
that key chain
around her you know what i mean i love
the foot measuring thing too
i kind of want one of those in my house
for the kids because their
feet are always ever changing and fun
fact
her flagship store is the old manolo
blahnik store where carrie bradshaw used
to shop
it's one of those moments full circle
thank you for that i also think when you
have a brand
a lot of things are direct to consumer
and you can't reach
the people and i think the fact that she
has a brick and mortar and can
engage you know with customers is like
kind of a dream come true for
people when you make things you do want
to share them and express so
i'm glad to see her making the most of
that well you have like flower products
you're going to be in like in the aisle
at the store
oh i would love to oh my gosh i would be
sjpinging out completely well you know
where i'll be later today i'll be at
that store
by the way i totally just thought like
yeah okay
um well the home of carrie bradshaw and
sex in the city themselves hbo max has
even more stores
and gifts in store for us oopsie and
including a friend's reunion happening
people reports that lisa kudrow says
she's already shot
scenes for the special and it will be
the first time the gangs back together
in one place
and they shoot in front of a live studio
audience this spring
ross have you seen friends once twice or
a thousand times
uh i have seen i've seen all of friends
and i i missed them i mean we we've been
on a break
get it that's a friend reference
everybody i'm wondering do ross and
rachel have
kids is central perk still open how's
the monkey
i have so many questions marcel yeah
you're a fan i can tell you
yeah and the hbo max hits keep coming
true we got one more
variety reports they've just ordered an
eight episode drama called
julia all about the life and career of
someone you're obsessed with julia child
i cannot handle how excited i am for
this well you know remember that movie
julie and julia my favorite movie ever
so great and it was one of those movies
i watched i thought i had no idea how
fascinating julia childs was when she
when i was a kid she was
just the woman oh like that
but there wouldn't be food television if
it wasn't i can't do it julia trump
mine sounded like mrs doubtfire just a
little bit
there would not be food television
i don't believe if it wasn't for julia
child she kicked off
a new genre she did and this show it
sounds like it's going to be amazing
sarah lancashire
will play julia and the cast includes
david hyde pierce
isabella rossolini and bb newworth
who is iconic we don't know when it's
going to be released yet but i know
you're going to be watching well it
can't come
soon enough i need this in my life and
she was just such a genius she was
groundbreaking
she was funny i loved her her food was
exceptional and she taught us all these
tricks and made us all home cooks
and speaking of food tricks and
geniusness
we've been obsessed with the particular
brand of food in ovation
that you can only find on tick tock of
course so
today if you're someone who loves your
sandwiches hot and toasty we're about to
blow your mind that's right i'm so
excited
i know okay i'm gonna bring in um
lifestyle expert michelle park
and hello michelle hi hi guys
i'm so excited that you're here and
guess what
we are gonna go to commercial break and
when we come back everybody stay around
because
michelle you're gonna teach us a toaster
hack that's gonna change our lives
yeah i mean i don't think julia child
would approve of this but i approve it's
really fun
i i i'm just really excited to learn it
[Music]